[Musique]
mesdames messieurs la r d and gentlemen
seigneur des seigneurs et à madame anne
roumanoff bienvenue à bord du vol à
destination de mont - intérieur je suis
constance votre commandant de bord notre
vol durera approximativement 18 minutes
la température est de 37 5 degrés est le
modèle de l'avion dans lequel vous allez
embarquer aide d'un mètre 69
je suis constance j'ai 18 ans je suis
une fille défend me dit même joli mais
je ne suis pas que ça je suis né dans
une famille formidable avec des parents
formidables qui m'ont donné tout ce dont
j'avais besoin
une jolie maison un frère une soeur et
un chat rigolo aussi coquine
c'est son nom je suis le produit de mes
parents je suis leur espoir leur idéal
leur prolongation
je suis aussi mon école j'ai appris ce
que je peux retenir de mes cours et de
m'aider me le dos mais le son des coups
de gueule avec les copines des histoires
d'amour avec les copains des larmes
d'amour et des rires d'humour des bonnes
notes et des mauvaises notes
je suis un produit une fabrication
sortante ou non tout de suite des usines
de la vie dans lequel on verse depuis ma
naissance
la nourriture de la société dans
laquelle je vis dans laquelle j'ai
grandi comme vous made in france
la télé internet
snap chatte me conforte à être une fille
de mon époque avec les vrais code de mon
époque je suis une vraie fille
totalement affûté et prêtes à
entreprendre la vie comme la pointe
d'une flèche destinées seulement aux
rouges du centre de la cible mais qui
suis-je
que suis-je vraiment vous connaissez
tous l'histoire de l'oeuf et la poule
qui le premier suis-je l'efs la promesse
de devenir ce que mes jeunes et mon
entourage me commande le corps que vous
voyez s'est imposée à moi mes rondeurs
sont marquées parfois même rue
arqués par vous messieurs mais vous
aussi mesdames ce corps je n'ai pas
choisi dans le magasin de corps de fille
où il y avait plusieurs tailles
plusieurs formes plusieurs modèles
plusieurs couleurs non je n'ai pas
choisi je n'ai pas eu le choix j'ai eu
un prototype à moi de faire avec
et pourquoi cet esprit c'est une glisse
et dans ce corps j'imagine souvent que
là-haut quelque part je sais pas où il
ya deux usines qui fabriquent en
fonction des commandes il ya une usine
de corps et il ya une usine à l'esprit
comment l'esprit s'était glissé dans le
corps est-ce qu'il s'est glissée au
hasard est ce qu'il ya un distributeur
qui mélange tout c'est pourquoi une
fille pensera comme un garçon est un
garçon rêve en secret devant une vitrine
de robes ou alors c'est la grande
loterie
mon esprit est ce qu'il serait le même
s'ils étaient dans le corde
angela merkel ou angelina jolie ou toi
vous est ce que ces mêmes femmes
seraient différentes en moi est ce que
vous vous seriez les mêmes en moi et
comment je penserai si j'étais de jolies
et que ma prend t-il ce corps que me dit
il ce corps il me dit que oui j'ai
grandi il me dit que je dois à grandir
que je dois mourir et si jamais j'avais
oublié le miroir me l'expliquera cette
chronologie anatomique ces corps ils
perturbent les regards il organise les
relations aux autres
on aime on n'aime pas on se positionne
les autres semblent affirmer des choses
à mon sujet que j'ignore facebook
personnellement j'en ai morfler et je
pense que je suis l'une des seules à
voir facebook dans cette salle et donc
moi aussi à mon tour j'affirme par
rapport à l'apparence de l'autre à 18
ans une fille c'est que son corps est
l'enjeu d espoir et d imagination de
tous de chacun
la grand-mère qui entrevoit le bon
mariage des petits enfants qui vont avec
la maire qui reconnaît ses gènes et
revendique l'inspiration de la nature
sur la qualité des fesses de sa
progéniture
le père qui voit sa fille comme une
création artistique absolue il la
regarde la contemple en se disant mon
intelligence est ici mon savoir là j'ai
fait ça lorsque regardera ma fille on
francs sera de moi que je suis un génie
génétique
je vais avoir une descendance dont on
parlera encore pendants millions ou bien
suis-je la poule celle qui ne se posent
pas de questions sur la qualité ni la
couleur des ses plus elle est une poule
et n'a qu'une solution sur terre faire
un oeuf végète docile à ma destinée
rencontrer des gens qui me ressemblent
et qui correspondent aux conventions de
mon entourage trouver un homme qui
m'aimera et qui deviendra mon mari un
bon mari et nous aurons une famille
formidable avec une maison formidable et
un chien formidable et des enfants
formidables et tout recommencera alors
être moi-même commence ici qui commande
qui dirige mon corps s l'avion qui
contrôle le pilote ou est ce le pilote
qui pilote est ce mon corps qui en riant
de mes réflexions
ou alors est ce que je décide d'être par
moi même je suis désolé je sais pas je
sais plus je crois qu'il ya trop de
questions être soi-même à 18 ans ne
trouve pas la même réponse
30 60 ans parce que à notre âge nous à
18 ans on a un fonctionnement
mais ne nous connaissons pas encore et
nous n'avons pas encore été instruits
des différentes leçons de la vie parce
que le rêve de l'humain qui pense c'est
de se projeter au-delà de demain par
exemple ce soir et à manger dans un
frigo mais demain ou qui vais-je
rencontrer tel feront mes enfants où
vais-je habiter à paris à new york à new
delhi à newman
quand j'écoute la vitesse de mes idées
dans ma tête je comprends pourquoi
certains ont recours à marie-jeanne
c'est une fille de joie simple facile
c'est pour ça que certains aiment dire
sel fumé leur faut obtenir un vide
immense qui ferait rougir davantage un
poisson rouge l'alcool apporte les mêmes
saveurs l'oubli de l'existence le
cerveau ton tout de suite moins vite et
on pense d'un coup comme une autruche ou
une poule mais ça fait du bien enfin
paré mais attention ne plus penser nuit
gravement à votre santé et celle des
autres mesdames messieurs virage dash
innocente vos ceintures nous entrons
dans une zone de turbulences mais
finalement nos craintes nos torts nos
imaginations nos corps nos affirmations
tout ça et si tout ça avait été commis
juste par erreur est-ce que l'erreur est
humaine
ou est ce que l'humain est une erreur
est-ce que l'erreur est présente en moi
comme le sang qui peut me guérir ou me
tuer
c'est l' équilibre de sa présence dans
mes circuits qui me maintient en
construit parce que que serait l'humain
sans erreur
que serait son univers sans l'erreur que
serait sa planète sans l'erreur
que serait l'amour sans l'erreur
l'erreur d'une rencontre où vient le
hasard d'une rencontre que serait la vie
sur terre tout simplement sans l'erreur
l'erreur est assurément humaine ne
croyez vous pas il suffit de contempler
la création % dissuader au départ il à
ce big ben improbable depuis le départ
mais pourtant des milliards d'années
plus tard
l'humain commence par cette erreur
pardon
ce malentendu galactique quelque chose
quelque part on ne sait où a fait
exploser un monde pour que le nôtre
vienne où quelqu'un me direz vous dieu
par exemple hypothèse sérieuse également
aurait tout fait exploser pour que tout
commence tout
alors erreur au hasard depuis le début
de la vie sur terre
l'erreur s'est immiscé dans les règles
du jeu du fonctionnement terrestre c'est
un peu comme son mode d'emploi son adn
pour que les mammifères arrive il
fallait que les dinosaures disparue ce
n'est ce pas alors pour que les dix neuf
heures disparaissent il a fallu une
erreur de trajectoire d'une météorite
est ce que la nature
aurait-elle était plus belle sans
l'humain est ce que la nature est elle
était moins abîmées sont humains
affirmer que oui c'est comme justifiée
que le lion serait toujours aussi
magistral qui ne se nourrissait que deux
limaces vous avez l'image vous voyez sa
crinière
vous la trouverez tout de suite beaucoup
moins ben moi oui j'ai besoin d'imaginer
le royal félin brutal et sanguinaire
courant derrière sa proie
pour justifier sa présence sur terre
pauvre antilopes humain lui quand il ne
détruit pas d'autres humains
réfléchissent la pertinence de son
existence et bien j'affirme mois que
l'humain fait partie intégrante du grand
calcul universel mes joies mes doutes
mes craintes
mais thor mes affirmations et mes
erreurs en font partie
le monde ne nous a pas attendu pour
créer la destruction l'humain n'a pas
inventé le feu le froid la mort le vent
les tempêtes la putréfaction la maladie
la puanteur la planète ne nous a pas
attendu pour se faire du mal avec les
tremblements de terre les éruptions
volcaniques les bouleversements
climatiques non humain n'est pas
responsable de tout ils participent ils
accompagnent le drame qui se joue comme
il participe et accompagne l'amour et le
bonheur qui vient c'est tout l'humain
n'est pas une erreur
il est la terre il a en lui dans son
corps dans sa peau dans ses gènes dans
ses veines dans ces molécules des
poussières des toiles imaginez en
fermant les yeux 5 secondes
est ce que vous pouvez faire mais s'il
vous plaît les yeux pendant juste cinq
petites secondes
imaginez un univers totalement vide un
univers sans aucune constellation sans
notre planète
imaginez que chaque atome qui constitue
mon corps que chaque atome qui
constituent votre corps existait déjà
avant la création de la planète que
chaque atome de mon sourire que chaque
atome de votre sourire elle vieux de
plusieurs milliards d'années
vous pouvez les réouvrir maintenant
l'erreur est à lummen oui oui mais oui
et heureusement que oui car ce qui fait
le succès de l'être humain
c'est ça qu'a fait c'est sa capacité à
apprendre et à comprendre par ses
erreurs et en faire d'autres encore et
encore sans ne jamais reproduire ces
mêmes erreurs l'enfant qui tombe et qui
grandit malgré tout avec son corps qui
sait puisque lui qui doit se tenir
debout sur ses deux jambes pour pouvoir
continuer à avancer
la chute lui enseigne le comportement
qu'il doit avoir
il faut se tromper souvent il faut
tomber souvent pour devenir humain et
savoir qui nous sommes vraiment alors
aujourd'hui
suis-je la poule où suis-je l'oeuf
je sais qu'aujourd'hui devant vous et
grâce à vous je brise un peu plus chaque
jour de mac os qui aujourd'hui être
aujourd'hui être soi-même que nous-mêmes
implique donc d'écrire notre histoire au
travers de l'histoire des autres
je regarde comment tu vis je regarde
comment tuer
je m'inspire un petit peu de toi un
petit peu de vous je mens visage comme
toi là-bas comme toi aussi je mens
visage comme toi comme vous
comme aujourd'hui j'ose être moi même
devant vous avec mes faiblesses et mais
fragilité je n'ai rien à vous apprendre
à vous enseigner mais je sais que j'ai
prévu de grandir dans l'existence de
tous de tous
je fais le voeu de trouver aujourd'hui
dans ma vie auprès de chaque être humain
l'envi de vivre ensemble je fais le voeu
que la tolérance remplacent les
certitudes et que la convoitise de
chrysalide et deviennent sagesse à vous
nos anciens avant le grand voyage
ne partez pas sans nous avoir dit tout
vos leçons ne partez pas sans nous avoir
dit combien la vie mérite d'être vécue
donner à ceux qui grandissent autour de
vous une charpente une construction un
projet l'envi de vous dépasser 2 vous
prolonger dans l'existence dites-nous
comme chaque époque a ses difficultés
six abandons celle achetée vous êtes les
piliers de cette terre si nous voulons
construire haut nous avons besoin de
fondamentaux nous avons besoin d'exemple
nous avons besoin de vous mesdames
messieurs la i10 and gentlemen seniors
les seniors est en moi une dame un
humain et le héron constance airlines
vous informe que nous sommes arrivés à
destination les pilotes et l'équipage
j'espère que vous avez passé un agréable
voyage que les nuages que nous avons dû
traverser vous permettent à présent
d'affronter bien en face le soleil la
jeunesse a toujours été et sera toujours
le refuge des tempêtes de la vie
avis à la population du monde et celle
de vannes que votre chaleur embrase mon
coeur est qu'aujourd'hui à mon tour
j'embrasse beau sourire de poussière des
toiles merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]